bonsoir à tous je dis 4 avril bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale du 7-8
journal de tv 60,18 si vous nous
rejoignez à 18 heures nous sommes en
direct depuis le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout de suite
c'est les titres l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise accueille la deuxième
édition de ce qu'ils emploient en piste
c'est l'événement emploi et formation de
l'agglomération qui se déroule depuis ce
jeudi matin et jusqu'à 20h30 ce soir
cinq mille offres de travail dans
différents secteurs sont proposées sur
place nous en parlons avec nos invités
150 entreprises ont répondu présent pour
le rendez-vous qui attendait pas moins
de 4000 visiteurs pour l'occasion le
vélodrome était divisé en cinq espaces
dédiés une journée rythmée par des
tables rondes conférences et animations
reportage à suivre au coeur de cet
événement
et puis le reste de l'actualité locale
et régionale la révélation aujourd'hui
des chiffres sur les opportunités
économiques et d'emploi pour les jo de
2024 la visite sur le territoire est de
le paix à paris saclay sans oublier la
fin de notre dossier sur l'union
européenne focus ce soir sur le
dispositif erasmus 7,8 journal depuis le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la deuxième édition de ce
qu'ils emploient en piste des invités
seront avec nous tout au long de cette
émission est un sera en grande partie
avec moi c'est roanne le gall bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle
alors cet événement vous l'avais pensé
quels sont les objectifs du ski emploi
les objectifs sont très simple c'est de
réduire le taux de chômage son
territoire et au moins de répondre aux
attentes de nos entreprises que ce soit
les grands comptes et les pme et les
artisans
voilà ça ce sont vraiment les axes que
nous ont donné depuis deux ans mais bien
avant évidemment avec des firmes d des
forums sur des formats complètement
différents mais là l'orientation précis
c'est vraiment vraiment de répondre aux
attentes de nos entreprises où on sait
qu'il ya des carences et des métiers en
tension
est ce que ça marche si vous vous basez
sur l'expérience de la première édition
qui s'est déroulée l'an passé alors bien
sûr que ça marche mais enfin vous savez
peut toujours se méfier de la rapidité
des résultats je le disais d'ailleurs
d'introduction ce matin c'est que nous
agissons sur saint quentin 1 après le
communiqué une fois que nous avons des
résultats
il est évident que depuis la première
édition nous avons eu un certain nombre
de résultats positifs mais on voit bien
quand même que le chemin est encore long
à parcourir et que nous devons encore
faire mieux alors faire mieux c'est de
répondre je les dis précédemment aux
attentes des entreprises
mais c'est aussi d'améliorer le concept
et le schéma voilà comment on peut
améliorer les choses par exemple c'est
les attentes qui lie à en 2017 2018 sur
les métiers en tension et les métiers du
numérique
on a mis en place un code numérique
voyez c'est ce genre d'action il faut
entendre il faut respirer il faut humer
un territoire et il faut faciliter ces
rencontres entre les demandeurs d'emploi
et les employeurs ils ont peut-être trop
difficulté aujourd'hui à se rencontrer
alors il faut faciliter ces rencontres
entre les demandeurs d'emploi les
employeurs et je vais même aller plus
loin il faut aussi faciliter les
rencontres employeur avec employeurs
parce que les problématiques et le
partage aussi de salariés le portage
salarial portage salarial c'est des
choses qui existent et aussi on doit
être enclin à faciliter ce genre de
choses alors ce deuxième ce qui emploie
en piste se déroule depuis ce matin 9h30
au vélodrome nationale 150 entreprises
présentent cinq mille offres d'emploi
avec des stands des stands à diviser sur
cinq espaces dédiés immersion dans ce
rendez vous avec mélanie poké nicolas
landry d'ici quelques minutes la journée
sky emploi en piste va être lancé au
programme près de 2500 entretien
d'embauché pour 5000 offres d'emploi
dans différents secteurs d'activité mais
cette journée c'est aussi l'occasion de
témoigner de proposer aussi des ateliers
et des conseils pour saisir les
opportunités
nous avons rejoint karin soûlard service
recrutement de france ménages ile de
france une entreprise spécialisée dans
leur passage et le ménage à domicile
bonjour aux hommes alors pourquoi vous
avez décidé de participer à cet
événement aujourd'hui écoutés
actuellement donc on recherche de
personnel dans ce secteur donc le
département du soixante dix huit pour
intervenir chez des particuliers
alors que le type de poste alors d'où ce
qu'on propose aussi des cdi à temps
partiel et les personnes travaillent
dans leurs zones géographiques
d'habitation
d'accord vous avez une dizaine de rendez
vous prévue tôt aujourd'hui en quoi
c'est une opportunité ce genre
d'événement bah en fait cela nous permet
également de proposer baky et la société
aux candidats de voir réellement le
candidat et voir réellement ce qu'ils
recherchent et si dans ces cas là on
peut travailler ensemble qu'à une seule
à merci beaucoup je vous en prie je suis
venu au vélodrome pourquoi parce qu'il
ya les forums de l'emploi
nous sommes dans un grand bassin où il
ya énormément d'entreprises donc si je
pense que c'est le rendez vous qu'il
fallait absolument pas rater
quelles compétences que vous mettez en
avant lors des entretiens mais mon
savoir faire ce que le tout les tous les
points que je vais maîtrisé après c'est
vraiment un échange je cherche un
travail éreintant commerciaux et
assurances ou ça quelles compétences
vous mettez en avant dans vos entretiens
que j'ai travaillé pendant cinq ans en
suisse dans des assurances et dans d
autres groupes ou par le contact avec
les gens il
le relationnel est très ouvert d'esprit
très technique c'est une entreprise
historique de saint quentin en yvelines
le groupe legendre spécialisée dans la
logistique globale et nous sommes avec
karine bois n'est responsable des rh
bonjour bonjour alors qu'est ce que
c'est la logistique et le global alors
le gentil un peu une entreprise atypique
avec le transport comme métier d'origine
et principal du groupe et qui s'est
diversifié dans divers domaines
d'activités comme la logistique
l'emballage industriel le transfert
industriel
le sourcil et la communication quelles
compétences doivent avoir les personnes
qui postulent à ces postes
alors aujourd'hui on cherche pas
forcément les compétences car on est sur
des métiers où on est on est en pénurie
de profils
donc on va plutôt être sur le savoir
être des personnes motivées qui ont
envie d'apprendre un métier qui a envie
de partager
notre métier de notre amour du métier tu
as une bonne et merci beaucoup
présenté mardi tout de suite à la
rencontre des associés de l'entreprise
éphémère présent aujourd'hui au
vélodrome nationale
et nous avons rejoint paris deux bannis
l'un des 50 associés de l'entreprise
éphémère myriade révélateur de talents
bonjour bonjour alors pour rappel
l'entreprise éphémère rassemble une
cinquantaine de demandeurs d'emploi dont
leur objectif est de rechercher un
emploi pour eux mais aussi pour
l'ensemble des associés alors
concrètement aujourd'hui au vélodrome
qu'est ce que vous faites sur le site
donc de ce salon nous allons démarcher
entreprises pour aller voir les besoins
éventuels et les rapporter pour la
collectivité savoir si elles ont des
besoins qui pourrait correspondre à nos
profils
nous avons été nous présenter auprès des
différents exposants et en expliquant le
concept certains ne connaissent pas donc
on en profite farid jouanny merci
beaucoup et je vous propose tout de
suite de partir à la découverte des
autres services de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines oui parce que
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a participé à ce projet c'est
le nouvel outil pour l'emploi lancé
aujourd'hui au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la plateforme
sky emploi développé par saint quentin
en yvelines et nous sommes avec ses
villes lanfranchi signol du service
développement économique bonjour bonjour
alors qu'est ce que c'est cet outil
c'est tout simplement un portail pour
trouver des offres d'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines pour les candidats
identifier toutes les offres près de
chez eux donc sur les douze communes de
saint quentin en yvelines et pour les
recruteurs la possibilité de mettre en
ligne des offres pour les les saint
quentinois et plus largement les
personnes qui souhaitent venir
travailler à saint quentin
comment fonctionne son site internet
alors très simplement là vous êtes sur
la page d'accueil vous pouvez entrer et
chercher par poste ou par type de
contrat vous avez une visibilité
et sur les recruteurs présents sur la
plateforme vous pouvez soit chercher des
stages ou des alternances soit trouver
des bons postes et pour les recruteurs
identifier mon profil vous avez des
entrées par commune et par métier et
vous avez bien sûr un agenda avec les
actualités disponibles céline lanfranchi
signol merci beaucoup et vous
téléspectateurs vous pouvez d'ores et
déjà retrouver ce site internet en ligne
sky emploi ça s'affiche en bas de
l'écran sujet de nicolas d andry avec
mélanie poquet pour les moyens
techniques alors avec moi en plateau je
le rappelle erwan le gall conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle
on l'a vu cet événement a été l'occasion
de lancer une plateforme ce qu'ils
emploient on y retrouve plusieurs offres
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines pourquoi il fallait se doter de
cet outil
l'outil est la continuité du de cette
journée il est important et c'était une
demande savez en 2016 2017 nous avions
mis en place les petits déjeuners que
les chefs d'entreprise et c'est quelque
chose qui remontaient ça où il y avait
eu il leur semblait qu'il y avait une
carence en termes de l'offre pour leur
entreprise dédiée uniquement sur saint
quentin en yvelines
donc nous avons une réflexion longue
certes mais il a fallu mettre en place
cette continuité quand j continue t ça
veut dire que leur rendez-vous 2020 bien
introduites 1019 et 2020 il y aura les
offres d'emploi des chefs d'entreprises
du territoire
les demandeurs qui pourront répondre à
ces offres
les chefs d'entreprise qui pose
posteront lors leur offre c'est gratuit
ou est ce qu'il ya un espace recruteur
et un espace demandeur dans le règlement
et c'est valable aussi pour les stages
pour l'intérim pour l'apprentissage pour
publics et privés c'est important de le
dire parce que on est on s'aperçut qu'il
y avait aussi une carence au niveau de
demandes de stage et on sait bien qu'une
une demande à un stagiaire peut conclure
derrière après
à voir après avoir obtenu son diplôme il
peut être repéré par l'entreprise et
revenez en entreprise et ça c'est aussi
fait d'élise et un certain nombre de
postes
ça serait dommage que nos jeunes parce
qu'on a quand même des belles écoles une
belle université sur notre territoire
c'est comme dommage que certains jeunes
partent ces exodes à en dehors du
territoire alors que on a plus de 16
mille entreprises on ne faut regarder
ses talents note notre bassin de vie il
est il est là il existe on retrouve bien
sûr cette plateforme sur le site
internet qui s'affiche alors l'événement
ce qui emploie en piste se déroule
depuis ce matin je le rappelle au
vélodrome nationale on va dresser tout
de suite un premier bilan avec deux
invités qui m'ont rejoint deux
entrepreneurs qui étaient présents sur
cet événement il y a karine bodet
bonsoir ça alors vous êtes directrice
des ressources humaines responsables des
ressources humaines pour l'entreprise
legendre le groupe legendre qui est
spécialisée dans la logistique globale
et nous avons également avec moi je vais
prendre ma petite carte puisque j'ai
déjà oublié son nom c'est alain berger
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
général d' art danse c'est un groupe
spécialisé dans l'ingénierie de la
connaissance
un petit bilan de vous deux vous allez
vous passer le micro sur cette journée
quel bilan quel premier bilan vous
dresser sur cette journée au ski emploie
déjà ce qui est extraordinaire pour nous
c'est d'avoir pris autant de contacts
puisque
j'ai eu à choisir parmi 50 candidats
donc cinquante candidats qu'on est une
société de 12 personnes c'est quelque
chose d'assez très précieux ensuite il y
avait des profils que nous cherchons des
profils assez rare puisque faire du
business dans l'ingénierie de la
connaissance tout le monde ne sait pas
faire et donc trouver des profils
atypiques
ça a été l'occasion de rencontrer des
gens avec des projets personnels qui
pouvait aussi se marier avec l'objectif
de l'entreprise des profits le site
d'informaticiens on a parlé de
l'attention sur le les marchés du
numérique
et comme nous sommes une société
d'autres technologies trouver des
profils pointus ben c'est une occasion
d'en rencontrer et on a évoqué le cas
d'apprentis il ya un apprenti qui pour
sa licence pro est venu me voir n'était
pas prévu dans les entretiens et ça va
peut-être se conclure et l'huile et il
n'est pas strictement sur saint quentin
il est sûr vélizy villacoublay
mais allez on va dire que en et sport ce
sont des voisins
alors pour vous tirer une bonne et on
vous a vu dans ce sujet vous dresser un
bilan sur la matinée la fin de la
journée qu'elle est il ce bilan toujours
très positif alors on a eu la chance
d'avoir à la fois un stand sur la partie
showroom est à la fois un stand au
niveau du job dating
on a vu au total une cinquantaine une
centaine pardon de candidats on est
aussi sur des métiers en tension sur le
transport la logistique et l'emballage
industriel qui sont présents sur le 78
et l'a clairement on a on a dvd profil
de poste qu'on va pouvoir recruter dans
l'immédiat et alors que nos annonces on
n'avait pas forcément de candidats qui
postulent et sur ces annonces la la ça
permet de les rencontrer de se présenter
de présenter le groupe
on avait nos responsables d'agencés
aussi qu'ils étaient là pour parler de
leur métier et créer du lien avec les
candidats
alors du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines on précise que l'événement se
termine à 20h30 ce jeudi donc ce n'est
pas encore terminé qu'est le premier
bilan vous dressez erwan le gall alors à
16 heures nous étions je crois plus de
visiteurs le premier bilan que l'on peut
tirer
il vient juste d'être dit la qualité des
visiteurs à la qualité des cv moi j'ai
fait le tour là entre 14h et 18h je peux
vous dire que hugh beaucoup beaucoup de
contrats enfin pré-contrat signé ça
c'est un vrai indicateur
c'est ça que je vais tirer du comme
premier bilan après pour le reste
écoutez je vois des gens épanouis
je vends des gens heureux parce que eux
aussi être demandeurs d'emploi être
recherche d'emploi c'est une mission
c'est un moment de sa vie mais ça peut
être aussi fait dans la bonne humeur
avec des belles rencontres et je peux
vous dire que j'ai rencontré des gens
passionnants à chaque fois je suis
toujours ébahis de voir cette cette
passion et drh et chefs d'entreprise qui
tiennent le gouvernail d'un d'une
entreprise et en ce moment c'est
extrêmement compliqué damian en réseau
comme la bonne humeur et la transmission
voilà alors le premier bilan c'est ça
beaucoup de visiteurs un niveau de
qualité qui est qui et la quittons
rendez vous et puis beaucoup de contrats
signés l'organisation en tout cas merci
merci pour ce premier bilan karine
boinet alain berger le ski emploi en
piste qui était aussi l'occasion de
fêter un anniversaire celui du pli qui à
20 ans le plan local pour l'insertion et
l'emploi est un dispositif financé par
l'agglomération et le fonds social
européen et qui s'adresse aux 26 ans et
plus son objectif est de mettre en place
un parcours d'insertion professionnelle
individuelle pour accéder à un emploi
durable ou à une formation qualifiante à
saint quentin en yvelines
onze mille personnes ont bénéficié de ce
plan en vingt ans on dénombre six mille
sorties positives dont 49% et de cdi
signée dans les six mois qui ont suivi à
ce plan c'est un dispositif
erwan le gall qui témoigne de la volonté
de l'agglomération de d'être pionnière
sur sur ces questions sur les questions
de l'emploi de l'insertion
professionnelle vous êtes repris vous
avez raison
pour moi l'insertion vient se bloquer
dans l'emploi d'accord il n'y a pas de
scission c'est l'erreur que souvent on
fait oui c'est important
l'insertion là le filigrane de de
l'emploi au niveau de l'insertion est
importante je me permets juste deux
repreneurs par rapport aux chiffres que
vous avez dit le taux de réussite du
plie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de
53% 53 % de sorties positives
c'est supérieur à tous les plis de
france voilà donc ça veut dire que oui
c'est important mais c'est important
mais ces chiffres là et cette réussite
elle est liée à quoi elle est liée au
dynamisme que l'on met en place sur st
quentin en yvelines avec nos entreprises
le lien qui lie à en permanence avec
toutes les entreprises du territoire et
le vrai facteur de réussite et c'est
pour ça qu'on a un taux de sorties très
très très fort et bien sûr que c'est
important
évidemment que lorsque vous avez plus 26
ans et que vous avez eu une entorse dans
votre vie et que vous êtes loin de
l'emploi
vous ne pouvez pas laisser ces gens là
au bord de la route alors il ya d'autres
dispositifs on n'a malheureusement pas
le temps d'aborder l'entreprise éphémère
dont on a entendu parler dans ce sujet
ou à 50 demandeurs d'emploi vont pendant
cette semaine à participer à cette
entreprise qui est un initiative un peu
inédite en france ils font d'ailleurs un
travail de sourcing au sein de cette
entreprise pour trouver un emploi je
voulais vous faire réagir à roanne le
gall sur cette actualité l'actualité du
jour c'est aussi cette présentation à la
plaine saint denis dans le 93 le comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 a dévoilé ce matin
les chiffres en matière d'opportunités
économiques et d'emploi pour l'événement
pour rappel le vélodrome où nous nous
trouvons fait partie des quatre sites
olympiques de saint quentin en yvelines
à accueillir des épreuves alors le
comité la table sur 150 mille emplois
générés grâce aux jo dès 2021 a par
exemple ce sont 78 1300 emplois dans le
secteur de l'organisation en 2024
principalement 60000 postes pour le
tourisme dans le service l'accueil ou
encore le domaine des transports
enfin onze mille 700 emplois entre 2021
et 2023 pour la construction de
deux sites voilà il ya des sites
également à construire il ya une carte à
jouer une vraie carte à jouer pour saint
quentin en yvelines à roanne le gall
alors évidemment qu'une carte évidemment
qu'il est une carte à jouer en qu'on
attend le gong
évidemment qui a une carte à jouer et
moi je suis pas inquiet il faut savoir
que aux 150 en libye nous avons au
canada ce coup qui est vice-président au
développement économique et qui est
aussi conseiller régional donc évident
que l'articulation à va se faire l'huile
dans les rouages
je m'inquiète pas et on va pas être mis
à côté vous l'avez rappelé quatre sites
olympiques sur notre territoire
donc évidemment que nous allons
participer et plus que de raison à ce
grand projet d'emploi au niveau 2 de
l'avenir sur les jo n'aura bien sûr
l'occasion d'en reparler dans de
prochaines éditions vac où le tueur et 7
longues séquences d'interviews
erwan le gall sur ce cet événement bien
sûr en piste pour l'emploi ce sky emploi
en piste qui se tient jusqu'à 20h30 ce
jeudi au vélodrome nationale le fait que
ça dure jusqu'à 20h30 aussi c'était une
volonté de le faire durer que ça puisse
durer jusqu'au début de la soirée
écoutez je profite de sa question pour
remercier l'ensemble des équipes qui ont
un vrai pour une belle réussite telle
que ce cet événement l'année dernière
nous étions jusqu'à 22h 22h30
on m'a dit erwan faut réduire quand même
à 20h30
moi j'ai pour projet comme que nous
fassions d'ici quelques années
l'événement mais qui dure toute la nuit
parce que on oublie les on oublie les
emplois de nuit les boîtes de nuit les
restaurants etc
bon bref c'est une pointe d'humour mais
oui ça a du sens parce que la recherche
d'emploi c'est pas 9h 17h et il ya des
gens qui ont une activité
professionnelle etc ont aussi peut-être
envie de venir
après leur journée de travail regarder
un petit peu ce qui se passe sur le
territoire et peut-être échanger avec
leurs futurs employeurs voilà et je le
rappelle ce qui emploie en piste c'est
ici au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à 20h30 ce
jeudi soir merci
erwan le gall je sais que vous êtes
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines délégué à l'emploi
et à l'insertion professionnelle
on reprend tout de suite un cours plus
normal dans ce journal 50 ans on y vit
qui fait partie des trois communautés
d'agglomération de le paix à paris
saclay l'établissement public
d'aménagement il organisait ce mercredi
une visite sur le thème de l'innovation
à vélizy-villacoublay dassault systèmes
permet à des start-up du monde entier de
profiter de ces technologies
grâce aux trois des expériences lab un
exemple d'open innovation que nous font
découvrir nicolas landry et aurélie oms
lancé par dassault systèmes il ya un peu
plus de trois ans le 3 d'expérience la
bête un laboratoire d'innovation ouvert
basé à vélizy villacoublay
objectif pour le leader mondial des
logiciels de création 3d mettre sa
technologie au service de scientifiques
on a un modèle de coeur parfaitement
exact qui permet à des médecins et à des
biologistes d'appréhender le
fonctionnement d'un coeur à des fins
pédagogiques ou pour préparer une
intervention sur ce campus dassault
systèmes accompagne également des start
up qui développe des produits physiques
capable d'améliorer la vie quotidienne
environnement urbain on les modes de vie
avec trois des expériences labels
peuvent bénéficier de l'aide des experts
et spécialistes pour prototyper et
industrialiser leur innovation
l'objectif c'est de passer du niveau
local où on accompagne un réseau local
d'innovateur à un niveau global et faire
en sorte que ces écosystèmes puissent
collaborer les uns avec les autres ce
challenge et apprendre ensemble
entreprendre ensemble parce que vous
savez quand vous avez une bonne idée
quelque part ou pensait être le seul à
avoir l'idée bas au même moment de la
planète vous avez une dizaine d'autres
personnes qui ont exactement la même
idée est donc de faire rassembler c'est
important
rise robotics est une entreprise
américaine créée en 2011 à boston
spécialisée dans la robotique elle a
développé une technologie qui remplace
les système de vérins hydrauliques et
collabore avec dassault systèmes à
l'origine réalise utiliser solidworks
qui est un produit de dassault systèmes
pour design et nos prototypes et simuler
des tests avec le temps nous avons
trouvé des ressources nécessaires pour
des projets de management de fabrication
et plein plein de choses de dassault
systèmes pertinente pour rise robotics
aujourd'hui trois d'expérience lab
dispose également de bureaux physiques à
boston en inde et bientôt en chine et
après ce rendez vous les journalistes
participants à la visite du cluster
paris-saclay se sont rendus à saint
quentin en yvelines dans les locaux du
ski cube plusieurs startups et ils sont
un cube est ainsi que leurs innovations
un établissement économique qui démontre
la complémentarité entre les territoires
qui composent le pea paris saclay pour
terminer ce journal la fin de notre
dossier sur l'union européenne nous
avons vu notamment son action dans les
yvelines ce soir focus sur un dispositif
que vous connaissez forcément erasmus il
a été créé en 1987 et il a permis depuis
sa création plus à plus de quatre
millions d'étudiants à d'effectuer une
mobilité les français sont ceux qui en
profitent le plus parmi les 34 pays
participants le reportage de marie
l'ania piceno chez julie sia il a des
souvenirs dans les placards et jusque
sur les murs sont petits souvenirs
puisque on n'habitait pas trop en plus
du molineux stadium et on a vu un match
là bas est sympa elle revient de cinq
mois en angleterre un semestre à
l'étranger qu'elle a pu effectuer avec
le programme erasmus
elle allaite à l'université de
wolverhampton et travailler dans un pub
avec son compagnon tous deux ans nous
aussi profité pour voyager à moi je sais
que j'avais peur de partir au début et
un conseil que je peux donner c'est
peut-être n'ayez pas peur parce que
vraiment c'est c'est un truc comme mon
affaire
on s'habille comme elle ils sont chaque
année une centaine d'étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines a effectué une mobilité avec le
programme erasmus
ruben quant à lui fait partie des
cinquante étudiants étrangers par an à
découvrir le vs q2 ali quand il est
arrivé sur le campus de guyancourt en
septembre l'expérience lui a tellement
plu qu'il a souhaité poursuivre un
semestre supplémentaires c'est une
expérience unique et surtout par la
langue parce que
je voudrais par les bienvenus la langue
c'est le premier le principal le
programme erasmus a fêté ses 30 ans en
2010 est une collaboration entre les
universités favorisée par l'union
européenne et la mise en place de
bourses facilitant les mobilités pour
les étudiants mais pas seulement
on a aussi tout tous les ans environ 15
étudiants qui profite d'une bourse stage
pour leur mobilité
et puis on à la mobilité et et
enseignants chercheurs mais aussi
quelques mobilité administratif par
exemple une collègue de tous les
services des bibliothèques est allé dans
une dans une formation à une université
30 partenaires levé sqr ainsi pu nouer
de bons contacts avec des universités à
l'international ensemble elles
développent des projets pédagogiques à
la bourse erasmus s'ajoute une aile de
la région ile-de-france et une aide à la
mobilité internationale sur critères
sociaux
l'objectif est de faire profiter de
cette expérience au plus grand nombre
d'étudiants possible il faut être ouvert
à l'étranger au bénéfice d'étudiants
l'étudiant qui est dans une bonne
université qui est bien accueilli il
il progresse dans ses études et le
développent des compétences qu'ils
n'auraient pas développer ici de la même
manière des études démontrent qu'une
mobilité à l'étranger permet une
meilleure progression dans sa carrière
professionnelle le pôle mobilité de l'uv
sqv situé à la maison de l'étudiant
marta pan une quinzaine de pays sont
proposés d'autres partenariats sont
également noué avec des universités hors
europe
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal édition spéciale du 7-8 journal
depuis le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'occasion
de la deuxième édition de ce qu'ils
emploient en piste merci de votre
fidélité merci également aux équipes
techniques et dans un instant c'est une
autre édition spéciale que vous
retrouvez celle du 7-8 loisirs
marylène iapichino sera depuis le parc
france miniature à elancourt à
l'occasion de la réouverture de ce parc
assez ce week-end belle soirée avec tv